Charlotte Charles and rad Seeger who's
campaigned with the family are here with
me now in studio and a very good evening
to you both and thank you for joining us
particularly in in person I know it's
been a roller coaster 36 hours roller
coaster three years for you and
Charlotte you said yesterday and I was
watching it live as it was all coming
out you said job done and and you've had
24 hours or so to process things is that
still your your overriding conclusion
yeah yeah it certainly is but yeah we
haven't really still had time to think
anything in we just haven't been to bed
barely we haven't slept we've just been
on the go so it's still very surreal
um I don't think it has really
registered with us the enormity of what
we what we have achieved as a family and
our little tiny team Harry but very
emotional
um extremely
exhausting yesterday
um but yeah we um we achieved what we
set out to achieve which was to make
sure that UK Justice was was seen
through and and it's so good to see a
crack of a smile on your face because
this extraordinary set of emotions I I
can only imagine you must have been
through but this is a moment that you do
deserve to enjoy and if you've been able
to a little bit despite the mixed
emotions yeah I mean you feel lighter of
heart a little bit you know it is
forever going to be broken my heart but
you go from feeling extremely tense from
from head to toe every fiber of your
body just not knowing what's going to
come next
and then to be able to experience what
we experienced yesterday and have that
lift of you know three years three
months almost of of pure fight and being
in that fight mode to then realizing
wow you know this is this is it we we've
done it we don't there's no more
fighting to be had you know what we've
got left to do is to make sure it
doesn't happen to another family ever
again and that's the next the next part
but yeah it I feel we all feel I think
that you know we we can grieve and we
can rest now and what a legacy that that
will be for for you and for Harry and
we'll come to that in just a moment but
rad I mean did you always think you'd
get to this point I know you've been
alongside Charlotte and her family
throughout and and maintaining that
fight but were there moments where you
thought you might not get this far well
if I'm the sort of person that I will
not take a project on or set an
objective unless I know I can accomplish
it and I would never have led this
family down the Garden Path there has
never been a shred of doubt in my mind
that we would get to yesterday simply
because of the Simplicity of it in no
civilized society do you get to kill
somebody and walk away and that's what
this family we're being invited to
except and with you you know your help
skies help it it gave us that launching
pad and once that momentum built up I
knew it was never going to stop and this
family had been in the headlines
consistently for three and a half years
despite Ukraine despite the pandemic
despite the cost of living crisis this
family keep popping up in the headlines
and that's because I think those of us
who who look at this family
see the the Injustice and the outrage
and that's just not how we do things
never a shred of doubt in my mind well I
mean thank you for mentioning Sky News
my colleague Lisa Dowd I think is the
one that saw the truth in this story and
obviously followed the facts and and the
truth but the person that deserves the
most credit is sitting right next to you
Charlotte Harry's mum uh and I have been
friends for 20 years we are neighbors I
don't know how many people know that and
and that's our involvement
her children are the same age as my
children that grew up together
I think this woman is a hero and what
we've all asked her to do
to front this campaign for us some of us
were peddling behind the scenes but
she's been the front person I think is
superhuman and extraordinary and she
deserves nothing but praise as the judge
said yesterday it's a calm dignified yet
persistent manner of her
conduct is of the highest order and and
should be recognized in some formal way
well indeed and Charlotte I just asked
rad if there was moments of Doubt over
the last three years I mean where did
you find the strength throughout that
period how did you keep keep pursuing it
purely the promise that I made to Harry
on the night that he was killed you know
I had no idea how hard it was going to
be
you just assume with a road traffic
crash that you know Justice is going to
naturally follow we knew the
circumstances already by the time we got
to the hospital that night or by the
time we left certainly
and I kissed his bruised lip and
promised him that Justice would be done
and that's all it's taken you know that
promise has just burned in the pit of my
stomach since the the moment I made it
family were present friends were present
they heard it and um
you never break a promise to your
children you make them a promise you see
it through if they can't trust a mum or
their dad who can they Trust well I mean
that's inspiring to to hear you say that
and as you said justice has been served
and you've honored Harry in doing that
um in terms of again reflecting on some
of the words we heard you say yesterday
24 hours later you you also described
answer kulis as as cowardlys is that so
you're overriding conclusion and likely
to be the one you you hold for the rest
of your life yeah absolutely you know we
could have been cowardly three years
three months ago we could have just
accepted what would be what we were
being told by the police by the UK
government
um effectively the US government that it
doesn't matter it's just a road crash
you know get on with your lives we could
have just accepted that and just
done as we were told but that was wrong
it's totally wrong it would still be
wrong
um so yeah we weren't cowards we stood
up for our child and we fought and we
faced absolutely everything
beyond what we would have ever expected
um so yeah I do think she's a coward it
would have been so much easier for her
to have come back this none of this
needed to happen
um she's caused that and and rad you
were particularly uh negative towards
the U.S government yesterday I mean
clearly Mr kulis originally argued she
shouldn't need to be in the UK for the
the sentencing because of safety
concerns and only when that was rejected
did the government the US government
step in and stop her from coming what
did you make of that it was an
extraordinary moment in court yesterday
when the judge criticized the US
government on Mr circulus because the
U.S government said they had advised her
not to return because it wasn't in
America's interests
and what a thing to say to a British
family they are here living in our
country but looking after their own
interests while they kill our children
that that's not how it works so yes I am
extremely critical of the US government
this is not a U.S government that I
recognize and something's badly wrong in
their decision-making process I know uh
my friends at the foreign office are are
really angry with the way they're
behaving James cleverly is has agreed to
a meeting with us hopefully that'll be
sometime next week There's clearly a
problem here that that has to be exposed
and as Charlotte says we don't bear the
Americans Neo will they are our friends
it's the US government that's the issue
and we must make sure that not only are
are the people here the Americans
serving here safe
uh we're entitled to be safe we live two
miles away from that base and as we
drive around I don't know what's coming
around the corner I'm extremely upset
with the US government
Charlotte as we uh start to wrap things
up I I wondered whether you felt uh
Harry's siblings the rest of your family
and friends have taken a similar modicum
of of strength and closure from the last
24 hours yeah they certainly have you
know they also feel that
relief I think just a huge relief
um
again very emotional exhausted
struggling to absorb the enormity of
what we have achieved so far
and um but it's good to see it's good to
see that you know there are members of
the family now that can smile and I
think along with me they can look up and
say you know Harry
we um we've done it so things are
improving slowly but surely and but but
as you said the Heartbreak will will
never be fixed above all Charlotte how
do you how do you remember Harry
ah
just before you answer can I say he's
left a massive gaping hole in our
community
yeah he was um he was an amazing lad
big heart generous kind
of
thoughtful
cheeky chappie loved his riding loved
his biking
um covered many thousands of miles in
just the three years that he was riding
um loved his I.T another reason why we
went down the the route of accepting the
video link he was all for I.T and
Technology
he was very intelligent very wise young
man and he had his whole future ahead of
him
um
he deserves a legacy to to be built and
his twin brother deserves to see that
Legacy be built and and you deserve to
deliver that Legacy thanks so much for
joining us and sharing sharing those
memories excellent thanks very much
Charlotte and rad